- Here's a fun thing I
found out about you though.
You nicknamed yourself, what is it?
- The Black Mamba.
- Okay.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I'm gonna just keep it family
but where'd that come from?
- Well, honestly I stole
it from Quentin Tarantino,
to be honest with you.
- Oh, right on,
yeah yeah, yeah.
- From the movie "Kill Bill".
But it was like, you know, if
you look up the black mamba,
the snake, it's extremely deadly.
- Get it, get it, Kobe.
- Extremely, you know
what I'm sayin', so like,
for me when I play basketball,
that's the space I go into.
Don't mess with me.
- It's like you're
Sasha Fierce.
- Don't talk to me--
Exactly!
- Yeah.
- Leave me alone.
- I need a name.
- Yeah.
- Maybe my nickname could
be Sports Ball (guffaws).
I'm just kidding.
I have to ask all my--
- Maybe White Mamba or some--
- White Mamba!
(hands clapping) I'm gonna
be White Mamba, I'm deadly!
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)
So wait, your name, your official
name is Kobe Bean Bryant.
So where did Kobe and Bean come from?
- I think it came from my parents
smoking something that was illegal then.
(audience tittering)
- I was gonna say you had
to have some fun parents.
- Something like that.
Yeah.
- "Let's name him beef!"
- I know!
- Yeah!
- The crazy, like, they literally,
the story that they've told me
is that they were sittin'
at a Japanese steak house
and saw Kobe beef on
the menu and was like,
"Oh, that's a good name."
(audience chuckling)
- Hey!
- [Kobe] And then my
middle name Bean!
- I've never met another one.
- So it's like, "You
want steak and beans?"
Like, what you talking 'bout here?
(audience and Kelly laughing)
Like what we doing right now?
- [Kelly] So where did Bean come from?
- My father's nickname when he played
was Joe Jellybean Bryant.
- Jellybean, all right, so your--
- [Kobe] Still don't
make any sense though.
- Your father played--
- Like, you don't
call me Bean, 'cause...
(Kelly laughing)
Jellybean?
- I'm trying to make it cool, Kobe.
- Nah, ain't no saving that.
(Kelly cackling)
- Your dad played too then?
- [Kobe] He did.
- That's amazing.
- He did, yeah.
He played for, what was
it, eight years in the NBA
and then played eight years
overseas in Italy, so...
- Right, that's right, 'cause I found out
you also speak Italian.
- [Kobe] I do.
- That's sexy, Kobe,
I'm just sayin'.
- Oh, thank you.
(audience whoops)
(Kobe chortles)
- I mean, did you wanna
say somethin' in Italian?
- Well, (speaks in Italian).
(audience cheers and gushes)
- Okay.
Okay!
What does that mean?
- It means, "Hello everybody,
it's a pleasure to be here."
- Okay, it sounded, it was cooler,
my meaning was cooler in my head.
(Kobe chuckles)
"Kelly, you so damn sexy!"
That's what I heard.
(Kobe laughing)
I filtered it!